We created the today layout
so why doesn't it show up?
The reason is because we're
using a simple CursorAdapter.
Remember that it creates a list item
for every row in the cursor,
but it only supports one item view type.
That means that all list items
must use the same layout.
If we want today's forecast
to look differently
we're going to need to create
a custom CursorAdapter.
That way we can have
multiple item view types.
Then we can have different
list item layouts based on what row
of the cursor we're looking at.
Note that the concept of item view types
applies to adapters in general,
not just the CursorAdapter.
If you open up the documentation
for CursorAdapter,
you'll see that it's an abstract class.
It contains two abstract methods
that you'll need to override,
the bindView method
as well as the newView method.
The newView method knows
how to return a new list item layout
but doesn't contain data yet.
The bindView method knows
how to take an existing layout
and update it with the data
pointed to by the cursor.